bonjour à tous et à tous et bienvenue
sur socialobus
[Musique]
je vous retrouve en ce mois de décembre
pour vous proposer des idées de cadeaux
sociologie pour Noël vous avez peut-être
des proches autour de vous qui
s'intéressent à la sociologie ou alors
vous-même vous intéressez à la
sociologie et vous voulez suggérer des
idées de cadeaux à vos proches et bien
cette vidéo est faite pour vous je vous
présenter des idées de cadeaux qui vont
de 0 euro à 55 euros j'espère que vous y
trouverez des idées intéressantes alors
on commence tout de suite avec les
cadeaux qui correspondent au budget de 0
euro la première année de cadeau c'est
d'offrir une invitation pour assister à
un événement de sociologie ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que vous pouvez
regarder les calendriers des universités
près de chez vous et repérez des
conférences qui sont ouvertes publiques
et proposer à la personne à qui vous
offre le cadeau de venir avec vous il y
a des conférences qui sont publiques
dans la plupart des universités et pour
vous donner une idée plus précise si
vous trouvez à Paris ou en région
parisienne le Collège de France propose
des conférences et des sessions qui sont
ouvertes au grand public et qui sont
gratuites pour vous donner une idée
actuellement il y a des conférences qui
sont données par Esther Duflot qui est
quand même prix Nobel d'économie et qui
tient un séminaire qui s'appelle lutter
contre la pauvreté de la science aux
politiques publiques et c'est un cycle
de conférence avec entrée libre donc par
exemple 4 janvier il y a une séance sur
marché du travail et migration le 11
janvier il y a une autre séance qui
s'appelle place aux femmes donc voilà
offrir une invitation pour ce genre
d'événement ça peut aussi aider à
franchir le cap de se rendre dans ce
genre d'événement parce que on ne sait
pas toujours qu'en fait c'est ouvert au
grand public vous pouvez aussi vous
renseigner sur les événements qui ont
lieu dans les librairies autour de chez
vous puisque des essaisistes peuvent
présenter leur ouvrage Les dédicacés etc
donc n'hésitez pas à consulter le site
internet des librairies les plus proches
de chez vous la deuxième idée de cadeau
à zéro euro c'est de créer une liste de
films de socio à regarder une liste de
podcasts sociologique à écouter ou
encore de compte Instagram à suivre si
jamais vous connaissez pas bien les
comptes Instagram film ou podcast vous
pouvez regarder dans la catégorie
société sur la plupart des plateformes
ça va vous aider à trouver par exemple
des un film qui correspondent à une
approche sociologique dans la catégorie
des cadeaux à moins de 20 euros vous
pouvez offrir un ouvrage de
l'Observatoire des inégalités la plupart
des ouvrages sont à 10 euros voire à
moins de 10 euros et ce en fait des
rapports sur les inégalités en France
sur la pauvreté en France il y a
également eu un rapport sur les riches
en France et pour quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse à la sociologie c'est
toujours agréable d'avoir un ouvrage
détaillé avec des données quantitatives
analysées ce sont vraiment des ouvrages
très qualitatifs très intéressants qui
vont forcément plaire à celles et ceux
qui s'intéressent à la sociologie autre
cadeau à moins de 20 euros pour les
personnes qui s'intéressent à la
sociologie ça va être tout ce qui
concerne la papeterie un carnet un stylo
ça fait toujours plaisir quand on étudie
la sociologie et pas seulement
d'ailleurs et vous pouvez aussi offrir
des affiches en fonction des intérêts de
la personne à qui vous souhaitez offrir
le cadeau vous pouvez par exemple offrir
cette belle affiche de Angela Davis qui
est une figure très importante de la
sociologie contemporaine ensuite pour la
catégorie qui va jusqu'à 30 euros vous
pouvez offrir un an d'abonnement au
magazine Sciences Humaines ils ont une
de Noël qui est vraiment assez
intéressant puisque l'abonnement annuel
en digital et papier est à 27 euros ça
correspond à 50% de réduction offrir un
abonnement c'est toujours une super idée
et là l'offre de Noël de sciences
humaines magazine est vraiment
intéressantes et puis évidemment si vous
avez un budget qui va jusqu'à 30 €, ça
vous laisse pas mal d'amplitude pour
offrir des livres alors je le mets dans
la catégorie des moins 30 euros parce
que les livres de sociologie peuvent
être assez chers autour de 22 25 euros
mais bien sûr vous pouvez vous les
procurer d'occasion au format poche au
format numérique et faire baisser un peu
le prix donc vous pouvez offrir des
classiques de la socio également le
livre sociologue qui a un bon outil de
repère sociologique mais c'est peut-être
un petit peu scolaire d'offrir ça à Noël
je vous conseillerais plutôt de vous
tourner vers les essais sociologiques
qui sont peut-être plus sympas à
recevoir à Noël alors évidemment il va
falloir que vous choisissiez des essais
en fonction des intérêts de la personne
je vous donne quelques exemples au
hasard mais si la personne s'intéresse
par exemple au féminisme vous pouvez
vous tourner vers des essais grand
public tels que ceux de Mona Cholet ou
encore le livre de Lucile pet le coût de
la virilité ou même aller un peu plus du
côté de la littérature avec Annie Ernaux
qui a récemment reçu le prix Nobel dont
les écrits ont une portée sociologique
pour les personnes qui s'intéressent
davantage aux causent environnementales
et animales vous pouvez faire par
exemple cause animale lutte sociale ou
encore des ouvrages de Bruno Latour qui
est récemment décédé que ce soit pour
ses écrits sur l'environnement et
l'écologie ou pour ses écrits plus
sociologiques comme changer de société
refaire de la sociologie et enfin pour
les budgets supérieurs à 30 euros vous
pouvez offrir de belles éditions de
classiques de sociologie par exemple je
sais que j'adorais qu'on m'offre et tu
signer ma famille une belle édition des
cahiers de prison d'Anthony gravci ça me
ferait vraiment plaisir parce que c'est
un texte classique de la sociologie et
il y a des éditions avec des notes des
préfaces etc qui sont très intéressantes
vous pouvez aussi par exemple offrir un
livre en version anglophone c'est des
éditions qui coûte toujours plus cher en
France donc ça peut être l'occasion de
faire un beau cadeau et d'ailleurs
au-delà des ouvrages classiques ça peut
aussi être un abonnement à une revue
universitaire parce que ces abonnements
coûtent malheureusement assez cher donc
si vous savez que vous avez un ami par
exemple qui a publié dans une revue ou
alors qui lit tous les articles qui
paraissent dans une certaine revue vous
pouvez peut-être lui offrir l'abonnement
et enfin si vous voulez sortir un petit
peu des livres et vous tournez vers
quelque chose de plus ludique il y a les
jeux de société de sociologie alors ici
je vous présente deux jeux de société
auxquels je n'ai jamais joué donc je ne
peux pas vous garantir que c'est bien
mais en tout cas ça on a l'air le
premier jeu c'est le jeu de société
capital qui a pour ce titre
gagnerez-vous la guerre des classes et
qui a été développé par les sociologues
Michel et Monique peint son Charlot il
est au prix de 35 euros mais vous pouvez
sûrement le trouver d'occasion également
et l'autre jeu de société dont je
voulais vous parler qui est le cadeau le
plus cher de cette liste puisqu'il est
au prix de 55 euros mais là encore
peut-être que ça se trouve d'occasion
c'est le Monopoly des inégalités qui a
été développée par l'observateur des
inégalités dont je vous ai parlé plus
tôt voilà pour cette liste qui vous
donne des idées de cadeaux sociologiques
pour Noël j'espère que ça vous aura
donné quelques idées pour vous ou pour
les autres si jamais vous offrez un
cadeau de cette liste n'hésitez à me le
dire en commentaire ou à me taguer sur
Instagram ça me ferait trop plaisir de
savoir que je vous ai inspiré si cette
vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la
liker à la partager à laisser un
commentaire et à faire vivre sociologue
je vous souhaite de très belles fêtes de
fin d'année à tous et tous et vous dit à
très vite sur ce
[Musique]